THINKING OUR STAFF WERE GOING
THROUGH A LOT OF HOOPS TO PULL
THIS LAST MINUTE HEARING
TOGETHER. AND. YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU WERE DOING THIS OUT OF
RESPECT FOR A COLLEAGUE CENTER
WEST SO I WHO HAS BEEN SUCH A
TARGET. ADVOCATE FOR THE
TIJUANA RIVER. CLEANUP EFFORTS.
AND IT HAS BEEN WORKING REALLY
HARD TO TRY TO RAISE THIS ISSUE
I KNOW HE HELD A HEARING DIMAS
SAN DIEGO THAT I ATTENDED A
YEAR TO GO YOU CAN COME UP.
SENATOR RELATING TO THIS ISSUE.
YEAH THIS IS A MASSIVE ENERGY A
REAL PASSION FOR HIM AND- ONE
IS ACTUALLY. REACHED NATIONAL
ATTENTION THERE WAS A FRONT
PAGE STORY IN THE USA TODAY.
NOW THAT I PICKED UP IN OHIO
COUPLE MONTHS AGO AND SAID YOU
COPY THAT BECAUSE IT IT REALLY
HAS REACHED EPIC PROPORTIONS IN
TERMS OF. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT OF POLLUTION THAT RIVER
SO. OUT OF RESPECT FOR YOU IN
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WE
DECIDED TO EXCEED YOUR REQUEST
TO. HOLD THIS LATE NOTICE
HEARING AND- WITH THAT WERE YOU
MAY PRESENT AS OUR FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAS TAKE
WILL FIRST. START. M. SENATOR
ALLEN PRESENT. ALLEN PRESENT
BATES. PRESENT AT DELHI. HILL
SKINNER. TURN AYE CASKEY OKAY
UNIVERSITY CENTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THE
MUCH MUCH RESPECT BUT I KNOW.
THAT YOU HAVE MUCH MORE RESPECT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT SO THAT'S
WHY. THEY THEY'RE PART OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT. BUT IMPORTANT PART.
OF SIMPLICITY PLEASE STATED YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD ON THIS ISSUE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS BUT THIS YEAR IN
PARTICULAR IS VERY CRITICAL TO
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM. SOME OF
WHAT WE'VE DONE. WELL AS A
LEGISLATURE IS TO PRESSURE THE
TO BRING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO THE TABLE. AND THAT WE HAVE
ALSO HAD A. A VERY BIG HELP
UNHEALTHY DELEGATION OF FEDERAL
REPRESENTATIVE SKIN ON ON ON
BOARD WITH. OF PRESSURING IB WC
AS WELL THIS IS THE PRINCIPAL
JOB IT THIS WAS THE REASON WHY
THEY WERE CREATED. US SEVERAL
DECADES AGO TO. MAKE KEEPING IN
WATER QUALITY OF A PRINCIPAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THEIRS. WE
ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT LAST YEAR
REQUESTS THAT THE- ATTORNEY
GENERAL. OF. BRING UP I LEGAL
ACTION AGAINST THE I. B. W. C.
FOR THIS MATTER. WE'VE ALSO AS
I'VE MENTIONED THIS YEAR
ALLOCATED FIFTEEN MILLION TO
DRESS IS A PROBLEM. FORTUNATELY
NO WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT A SINGLE
STEP CLOSER. AND THIS THIS IS
AN URGENT MATTER THAT IS PUT
FOR POLLUTING OUR OUR COASTAL
WATERS IT'S JEOPARDIZING. THIS
BEAUTIFUL RIVER VALLEY WHICH
HAS BEEN LOCATED THERE'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE U. N.'S RAMS
ARE COMMITTEE IS A RAMSAR SITE
THERE ARE VERY FEW ROOMS ARE
SITES IN THE WORLD BUT THOSE
ARE USUALLY. IMPORTANT ECO
SYSTEMS THAT ARE UNDER THREAT
AND THAT NEED TO BE RESTORED
FOR THE BETTER FIT FETTERMAN OF
OUR PLANET THIS IS ONE OF 75%
OF ALL THE BIRDS FOUND IN NORTH
AMERICA CAN BE FOUND IN THIS
FOR VALLEY SOME PART OF THE
YEAR AND WERE MAKING THIS.
ENVIRONMENT OF A PARTY HARD
HOSTILE PLACE FOR THOSE
CREATURES AS WELL AS OUR OWN
FAMILIES OUR OWN CHILDREN AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THAT USED TO
BE A SALMON CANNERY THERE USED
TO BE VERY HAPPY HEALTHY SALMON
POPULATION THAT WAS ENDEMIC TO
THAT RIVER THAT IS NO. NO
LONGER IN EXISTENCE. AND THAT
IT'S JUST A SHAME. AT THE VERY
LEAST IF WE COULD CONTROL
RESTORE WATER QUALITY TO THIS
RIVER. IT WOULD BE A HUGE.
ACHIEVEMENT AND OF COURSE WE
NEED A BI NATIONAL SOLUTION AND
THIS RESOLUTION IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT. IT GETS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON TASK TO
NOT ONLY SUPPORT. OF OUR
POSITION ON RESTORING THE RIVER
VALLEY BUT ALSO TO ALLOCATE.
RESOURCES HUMAN RESOURCES AND A
STATE A POSITION IN SUPPORT. OF
CLEANING UP THE SUPPORT
ESTUARIES FAST FREE SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE.
OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO FORCE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE.
WE WANT TO RAISE OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS. OKAY THE ITEMS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS COMMENTS AND FIRE VICE
CHAIR. OKAY. SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS. YES IN A
BATH. I JUST WANT TO THANK
OFTEN IN TWO WEEKS SO WITH WITH
WITH CRITICAL CRITICAL ISSUE WE
KNOW BUT HE'D HAVE HAD THE
PASSION AND THE PERSEVERANCE TO
CONTINUE BRING IT FORWARD I
THINK I YOU RECOGNIZE THAT TO
US CENTER ALLEN BUT I WANT TO
ON BEHALF OF MY CAUCUS IT FOR
THE SIGNIFICANT IF ANYBODY'S
VISIT IN THERE THEY KNOW. FULL
THANK YOU ARE SENATOR WAYS
THANK YOU SENATOR. COULD YOU DO
IS JUST I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A
BILL ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL
COULD YOU CAN GIVE US A SENSE
OF HOW THAT'S COME ALONG AND
WHAT YOU HOPE. TO GET OUT OF
THAT. OF THAT BILL IS CURRENTLY
IN APPROPRIATIONS SO WERE
HOPING THAT IT GETS OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THAT BILL.
WOOD IS INTENDED TO. BE THE-
THE COMPANION OF THE- OF THE
FIFTEEN MILLION THAT WERE ABLE
TO PUT IN THE BALLOT. BALLOT
AND THE IDEA IS THAT BILL.
IDENTIFIES THE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE UNDERTAKEN WITH THOSE
FUNDS. OKAY THE MEASURE SPEND A
MOVE BY CENTER BATES
ASSERTIVELY KALRA. ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. SENATE AT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SEVEN I SENATOR WHO
HUESO. THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES. HI
DOLLY DALY AYE HILL HILL AYE
SKINNER STERN BY KELSEY. OKAY I
DO WE KNOW. PUBLIC HEALTH IS
NOT THE OTHER TWO WERE SO. OKAY
SO WE WANT TO. NO WAY OUT WE
HAVE YET TO THE MEASURES PASSED
OUT OF THE GROUND FOR THE FIVE
MINUTES THAT OKAY FOR THEM TO
DO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU WOULD MIND. ALSO CALL TEXAN
AND PERSONALLY SIR. WELL. THE
SENATE. ALL RIGHT. SO WERE YOU
LOOKING AT STERN AND SKINNER
YEAH THANK YOU BRENT. YES OKAY
THE RESTAURANT IS A GOOD ALSO
.
YES YES. YES OKAY LET'S SAVE IT
WITH YOU CAN DO THAT WITH YOUR
VOTE TODAY THIRD THIRTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON SR FIFTY
SEVEN. ITEM NUMBER ONE S. R.
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR WHO A
SELF MOTION IS BE ADOPTED FOUR
ZERO. SKINNER LEARN STERN AYE
AYE CASKEY. OKAY WE WILL HOLD
OPEN FOR ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES
AND I'M GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE
IN FIVE MINUTES. I KNOW. I KNOW
.
THE YEAH. DO YOU CAN YOU I KNOW
THAT YOU CAN TELL YOU CAN. FOR
ME SOME COMMENTS TO THE PUBLIC.
ON THIS. ALL RIGHT WHAT WHAT
ARE WE AND AS A DURING THIS
MEETINGS AS AN AFFAIRS OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MAKE
IT AS THE MEASURE HAS PASSED
FIVE TWO ZERO AND WITH THAT
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
ABOUT QUALITY COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED AND I DO WANT TO.
ONCE AGAIN REITERATE MY REAL
THANKS TO THE STAFF FOR PULLING
THIS TOGETHER AT THE LAST
MINUTE GREAT ANALYSIS AND- ALL
THE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED SO
THANK YOU AND THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED